you work here
no Esther I'm picking up your trash
because I don't work here
don't forget you have a dermatologist
appointment today also can you deposit
mom's disability check growing up I was
told my parents were special when I got
old enough I realized that's the word
adults use when someone has a disability
who's that he looks thirsty look at her
the part of her brain that makes her
horny is still working she just wants to
give him something to drink it's the
worst that could happen
oh
[Applause]
I don't think they can take care of a
child what choice do we have my mother
named me after her favorite cartoon
character hi Bambi now you know what B
is short for but hey at least we were
happy
I know bees childhood was somewhat
non-traditional I don't want to do this
anymore you said it would be fun and
it's not fun you gotta learn how to
drive I'm 10.
if that hasn't stopped her from enjoying
it well everyone was busy worrying about
my future I'm still waiting on those
college applications I know I was just
trying to balance work school and caring
for my parents is that why you never
want me to come over no it's okay
everyone's embarrassed by the parents
hi come on in man with your grades and
extracurriculars you have a shot of
getting into any college I can't you can
no I mean I can't leave
my whole life I've been torn between
wanting to get away from my parents
and wanting to care for them
because you
know you convince yourself that they're
helpless
[Music]
we spent a very long time worrying about
other people I think it's time to focus
on you for a while
[Music]
but one of these days are gonna move out
get married and that's what kids are
supposed to do a whole new world with an
unknown future shoot for the stars
you'll hit the roof
kind of a messed up saying
[Music]